man monkeys got it made a prehensile
tail I want me one of those someone tell
that monkey I want two prehensile tail
to wait that's no monkey it's not even a
primate it's this silky anteater the
most adorable of its insect-eating kind
if it looks fake derp sleepy too
that's because it is sleepy I mean the
silky anteater is a nocturnal hunter so
it's a bit out of sorts here in the
daylight but at night it makes its way
through the trees hunting for cheetahs I
just of course it's ants using those big
claws hit rips open bark to get at the
colony within snatching up the ants with
its long sticky tongue the silky
anteater is careful to move along
quickly so the ants don't have a chance
to overwhelm it with bites and stings it
only manages to snatch one percent of
the ants in a column the silky anteater
has his own pet udders to worry about as
well enter the heartbeat eagle perhaps
the world's most formidable Raptor with
talons five inches long and a wingspan
of six and a half feet it could snatch
an anteater right out of a tree no
problem which is why this silky limits
its movements to the evening hours so
stay safe little one and maybe consider
some Visine